title 42 restrictions at our southern
border with mexico are set to end on
monday may 23rd we have seen it coming
but a federal judge could rule today on
whether the biden administration can
even lift the trump era pandemic policy
which has been used to expel a majority
of illegal immigrants since march of
2020. the looming end of title 42 is
stoking fears of an even larger surge
than the record numbers we've already
seen
border agents report 1800
apprehensions in the del rio sector in
just the past 24 hours alone
700 in the last three days in the rio
grande sector
critics say vice president kamala harris
remains noticeably silent absent on the
crisis despite being well in charge of
it all she's the borders are
over the past 14 months since she got
that title
it's pretty clear to everybody that she
does not ever intend nor has she ever
truly intended on addressing the crisis
at our southern border so many people at
a certain point look at this and they
say you know the fact that she's not
even pretending to try here coupled with
the fact that our government continues
to allow our laws on the southern border
to be flagrantly violated on a daily
basis perhaps not only do they not care
about it maybe this
administration wants these people to
continue to come in
tennessee senator marcia blackburn
serves on the judiciary comm committee
armed services and veterans affairs
committees as well great to have you in
focus in person with you so wonderful
so let's just pick it up with the basic
math here
we have a lot of people coming already
it's about to become more gop has stood
in the way a little bit though i mean
you you are protecting america from this
a little bit can can you stave off
what's going to happen we certainly
would like to we're very concerned right
now 6 000 people per day is about what
the border patrol is dealing with when
title 42 goes away they anticipate this
is border patrol's number that it will
be 18
000 a day
so
look at that from 6 000 to 18 000 the
cartels are global organizations
last year they brought people from 160
different countries to our southern
border
among that you had about 40
known terrorists that were apprehended
so harris this is what the border patrol
is dealing with and this is why for 30
years they have been saying we need
three things we need a wall
we need better technology we need more
officers and agents on the ground and
they thought they were going to get that
wall they're not now title 42 remain in
mexico things that helped them
to to stave off the influx of illegal
injury whether it's drugs whether it's
human trafficking gangs sex trafficking
now that is going away
let's talk about the terrorism uh the
potential for it because of who's coming
across the border
uh former
ice acting director under president
trump tom holman told me this week
that about 700 000 getaways
do we have any idea of how many of them
could be on them
and here is the thing
there are about 700 750 000
known got aways those are the ones they
saw on surveillance
and they couldn't get them
and these are the really bad guys with
the drugs the fentanyl that is killing
so many people in this country now
here's the thing that border patrol will
tell you and i'm sure whether it's mark
morgan or tom holman
you see some of the got aways but what
about those that you never see on
surveillance
so is the number a million is it 1.5
million do you think it could see they
don't know they don't know and there's
not a way to quantify that
because there is not a wall there is not
surveillance they are not able to secure
parts of the border and then target
their resources to areas where there
cannot be a wall this is why border
patrol has said
a physical
barrier services and impediment to
people trying to become i know who knows
that vice president kamala harris
because she's from california and they
have a wall
yes they do san diego and look at how it
is improving the situation there you're
exactly right i'll get to this here's
florida governor ron desantis signing a
bill increasing punishments for fentanyl
trafficking as the opioid crisis is
getting worse
we can and must lower the demand for
drugs through education and outreach
programs but we also
must fight the supply of drugs and crack
down on dealers and traffickers
particularly of substances like fentanyl
we're going to do all we can to decrease
the prevalence of fentanyl in florida
and that means if you're dealing
fentanyl
you are killing people and you are going
to be put in jail could we do that at
the federal level
it
we should be i was talking with one of
my sheriffs in northwest tennessee and
he said marsha 80 percent of the drugs
we apprehend are either fentanyl or it's
something laced with fentanyl
they're even taking gummy bears and
rolling them in fentanyl and this is how
they're going after younger
children that they can addict to this
eighty percent of the deaths in some of
our counties are fentanyl related
overdose deaths eighty percent of the
overdose deaths but harris these people
ought to be locked up they are causing
people to lose their life they're
actively
selling these drugs and the bad thing is
these are cartel
groups that are pushing this they have
set up their hubs in u.s cities a lot of
these
sanctuary cities they're working on our
soil and they all ought to be locked up
i want to get to the baby formula but i
have to ask about the vice president
kamala harris
m.i.a missing in action what's happening
there
we don't know don't see her she comes
every once in a while to
break a vote and break a tie on a vote
but i wish that she would take the lead
on the border because
these cartels are abusing women and
children
and that needs to stop
all right we'll let you wrap it there
and move to this critics are also
lighting up the biden administration
over the baby formula emergency and how
long it has taken for them to even
recognize it let alone try to respond to
it here's pentagon spokesperson john
kirby trying to explain how imports and
the president invoking the defensive
production act will work
right now the the principal job for the
military will be to work with hhs
department of agriculture the fda
to help provide contract commercial air
to move
formula from overseas particularly
europe to the united states
but that still doesn't tell us how much
longer shelves will remain empty with
doctors warning mothers again please
do not dilute the formula or try to make
your own but come on what are the
options at this point the supply
nationwide averaging at least 40 percent
out of stock
senator i i spoke with senator josh
hawley of missouri last week and he said
he was one he's in one of the first
states where they hit that 50 percent
threshold and he said then we knew we
were in trouble because there's not
enough to help us now that's in the
bloodstream
yes and 54
of the baby formulas are out of stock in
tennessee out of stock
and
yes and you know
we have been saying for weeks to the
white house give some waivers to import
from canada eu uk and they chose not to
do that why oh what reason
no we don't know they they just did not
do that
then
you you look at the factory in michigan
and harris they could have opened that
fda could have opened that
they knew back in february that they
should have been opening that because
back in february we were at a 25 percent
outage rate nationwide
they could have taken care of this that
one factory makes 40 percent of all the
baby formula and wait time i got to slow
you down in three months less than three
months we went from 25 percent to over
50 percent in your state yes out of
stock and nothing happened between
doubling where our losses were in
february what does this administration
do they wait for a problem to become a
crisis they make the wrong decision and
then they have to come back and try to
fix it which is what they're doing now
with the waivers and with the defense
production act this never needed to
happen we have two children in tennessee
that have been hospitalized for lack of
formula every time i talk
with some of these parents it is
very emotional i i just
i i cannot even you're a mom i'm a mom
and a grandmom
and you know it is just heart wrenching
it's unfathomable what these children
are going through and they're calling
family members and friends in other
states and saying can you see if you can
find some i'll pay you to fedex it to me
and and what you've told me
from this conversation is that the white
house simply doesn't hear or didn't hear
and now they're trying to play catch-up
i tell you that's a dangerous game
because young lives are at stake and
throughout the pandemic we know they
said they care don't they care now i
just don't get it
senator thank you for being here i'm
delighted and being here i appreciate it
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now